foreign
[Music]
s in world history ruled out of Rome by
a man named Caesar Augustus who
understood himself to be the son of a
god
is about to be challenged by a baby in a
Manger
the audacious message of the Old and New
Testament is in the time of the
Egyptians the Babylonians the Assyrians
the Greeks and the Romans the god of the
universe actually revealed himself to
humanity this is the message that this
God that is transcendent
is also imminent
the Roman Empire enters into absolute
insanity and to have empire-wide
persecutions it truly is miraculous that
Christianity has survived to the 21st
century in order to understand the
religion we claim you need to step
outside it and see how different it is
from other things like it and as a
matter of Faith you can learn where all
that comes from the heights of all of
this is the Incarnation of God this is a
god that is not only willing to die but
is able to die
how do you explain such a thing what
kind of words what kind of language do
you use this is the challenge of the
early Christians out of the collapse of
the western half of the Roman Empire
comes pure chaos but out of that chaos
comes faith I'm Ken Calvert this is our
course on Ancient Christianity let let's
begin
[Music]
foreign